the United States Department of Defense  just released its report on China's  military power and it is scary the  report talks about how China is quote  the most consequential and systemic  challenge to U.S national security end  quote and how their military is  basically preparing for all-out war  China conducted 135 ballistic missile  tests in 2021 according to the report  that's more than the rest of the world  combined China has been building up its  nuclear Arsenal fast they have over 400  nuclear warheads already and by 2035  China could have as many as 1 500  nuclear warheads China's military has  also been training in realistic  simulations and with virtual reality  they've done over 20 different  hyper-realistic Naval exercises that  involved capturing an island which  sounds a lot like Taiwan